Let's dive deeper into the similarities.
Building the portfolio apps for
the iOS nano degree,
you've become intimately familiar with
the classes and foundation and UI Kit.
Those classes are bridged to Swift.
But as you may know by now,
many of those classes are actually
written in Objective C.
This means that the way they're
used in Objective C will look and
feel very similar to the way
you use them in Swift.
Let's take a look at an example.
The following code snippets are taken
from a custom view controller class that
inherits from U.I. view controller.
In the code snippet here,
you can see the familiar U.I.
view controller method, viewWillAppear.
The Objective-C syntax will certainly
seem foreign at this point but
let's focus on what we can find in
common between the two implementations.
Just as you would do with Swift,
you start out by calling the
viewWillAppear method of the superclass.
After that, you call any methods
necessary to prepare the view before it
appears, in this case
the method displayResult.
By the way, if you ever find yourself
needing more time to read through
the code examples,
go ahead and pause the video.
Let's take a look at another example.
Here are some of the methods
of the AppDelegate Protocol.
You'll notice that if you create a new
project template in Xcode, whether it's
an Objective-C or Swift, the same six
AppDelegate methods appear by default.
I'm just showing the first four here but
you get the idea.
And here they are in Swift.
And here they are in Objective-C.
These methods manage transitions between
the five main application states.
Active, background, not running,
inactive, and suspended.
These five states are language agnostic.
And the transitions between them
are handled identically in Swift and
Objective-C.
As an iOS developer joining a new team,
digging through your colleagues'
Objective-C code, you can expect to see
many familiar classes and
methods from UI Kit and Foundation.
Let's talk about another similarity
between iOS development in Swift in
Objective-C, design patterns.
Whether you're writing in Swift or
Objective-C,
you'll be using principles
like the delegate and
Model View Controller patterns to
guide the architecture of your app.
For example, in conjunction with the
delegate pattern, both Objective-C and
Swift make extensive use of protocols.
Part of the need for
protocols stems from both languages
having single inheritance.
A given class can only
inherit from one other class.
Instead of multiple inheritance,
both languages employ protocols to share
functionality across unrelated classes.
Let's take a look at an example from the
familiar UITextFieldDelegateProtocol.
Here's an implementation of the
shouldChangeCharactersInRange method for
a text field accepting a zip code.
Here it is in Swift, and
here it is in Objective-C.
Here are the two signatures together,
and
here we see the body of the method for
each.
Notice that the two implementations
are incredibly similar.
The use of protocols across Objective-C
and Swift engenders continuity across
iOS apps at the scale of app
architecture and on a more
granular scale, as the two languages
employ many of the same protocols.